- [Retsuko] I can't get hurt anymore.
I'm no one special in the
grand scheme of things,
it's time I live with
my feet on the ground.
10 more seconds, yeah?
That's all I'm asking for.
(metal music)
- [Gori] Invest it, what do you say?
- [Retsuko] What, give you my money?
- [Washimi] Well Gori's new
project's in need of capital.
- [Fenneko] If you keep
blowing cash on your
virtual boyfriend you'll
end up in the poor house.
(engine accelerates)
- [Retsuko] Uh, I'm so
sorry. Are you hurt?
- [Hyoudo] As such I hereby appoint you
accounting director for the group.
Not a bad deal, right?
- [Fenneko And Haida] So what's the deal?
- [Retsuko] Nothing,
I'm just a little beat.
I don't have enough money for this.
Especially not now.
- [Fenneko And Haida]
She lied to our faces.
- [Retsuko] It says
I'm accounting director
but I'm just a gopher.
- [Hyoudo] You really think
we're selling them the music?
We're offering them the fan experience.
- [Manaka] You're not even woman enough
to stand up for your own dreams.
I know which one of us I'd rather be.
- [Haida] Why can't
she just tell us stuff,
what do you think we are to her?
- [Fenneko] We're those
friends you see at work.
- [Retsuko] I don't
know what I want to do.
Those people have no idea.
(screams)
(soft music)
When I count to 10, I'm...